good Morgan good marine
welcome welcome to KSP today we're going
to build the rocket to this space these
are my faithful comrades Dimitri
balalaika and Adam let's begin okay
let's begin the command pod very good
yeah and then we put this as if Z fuel
and a Z is zero key
yes very good okay launch I study
engineering I know how to do this
what Oh God
there we go oh oh oh oh oh oh damn it
hey it's intact oh my god go post [ __ ]
sake
I'll get Jimmy go
why here we go oh that was kind of short
go oh my god oh my god look at that face
stay it steady steady steady
what the [ __ ] are you going
all right I'm built a [ __ ] so hard life
is so hard all the second-stage tanks
now pressurized 35 seconds and counting
as the Knights report it feels good t
minus 25 seconds
20 seconds and counting
t-minus 15 seconds guidance is internal
12 11 10 9 ignition sequence start
yes oh my god I can't believe we're
doing this
this is amazing radda fuel and gate it's
engaged Oh what is that sound that is
the sound of freedom America I mean -
line space is the final frontier
we might just fall back on earth I'd be
so any climatic yep that's what
happening okay that's it that's his
[ __ ] gray this game is really really
fun when you actually get somewhere at
your school Yap look how it dangles yep
that's that's safe don't worry
come on come on come on
why should I want spaceships when you
can play a lot of spaceships NASA needs
to hire me like Jesus Christ look at
this Oh God
okay that happened I I'm not responsible
then I forget did I forget that the duct
tape was that it damn this [ __ ] is
burning jebediah what are you doing
outside then rocket Oh God
Shepard it's like [ __ ] this everything
is overheating okay we need to engage
disengage there we go
this is [ __ ] awesome look at that
look at that
why see in space no oh we were so close
so close to be in orbit okay first of
all this will burn this will pop off
then this will start and that will pop
off that's the plan bros kawaii doesn't
shine we can do it come on oh god it's
not very stable
oh no Sableye Sableye Sableye Sableye a
place that then did it end and did it
and did it it it it they're out of fuel
take them away
engage second rocket just face spinach
just [ __ ] face alright let's see where
he goes oh it's going out there okay
we're orbiting around the Sun yes
alright friends I'm gonna have to end
that episode there I really got into
this game I did not expect it to be so
awesome
I'll leave a link to the game in their
description you can check it out
yourself see if you can make it further
out in space and I I don't I don't think
so ah thank you both so much for
watching and leaving in like I really
appreciate those and as always stay
awesome breasts last step Rose for our
pika pika
pig pig
yeah ain't no pic a [ __ ] for that NOPD
tail oh my god let's go
so this is our rat tail looks like this
is our pic a chief tail look like what
the [ __ ]